- [Narrator] Russian
State Media has reported
that jailed Wall Street
Journal correspondent,
Evan Gershkovich has been formally
charged with espionage,
an allegation that The Journal
and the US government vehemently deny.
- The charge of espionage is ridiculous.
- [Narrator] His detention
is the first case
of an American journalist arrested
by Moscow on allegations of spying
since the Cold War,
and has prompted a growing
list of individuals,
organizations and government officials
to call for his release
On March 29th, while on a reporting trip,
Gershkovich was detained in the city
of Yekaterinburg around
800 miles east of Moscow
by Russia's main security agency.
On March 30th,
Gershkovich was seen being escorted
into a vehicle after
appearing in a Moscow court.
The press service of the
court said he was ordered
to be held in custody until May 29th,
according to state news agency TASS.
Russia's Federal Security Bureau said,
"Gershkovich acting on the instructions
of the American side,
collected information
constituting a state secret
about the activities of
one of the enterprises
of the Russian
military-industrial complex."
The Journal said it
"vehemently denies the
allegations from the FSB
and seeks the immediate
release of our trusted
and dedicated reporter, Evan Gershkovich.
We stand in solidarity
with Evan and his family."
The arrest of the 31 year old reporter
marked the latest diplomatic flashpoint
between Moscow and Washington.
- The targeting of American citizens
by Russian government is unacceptable.
We condemn the detention
of Mr. Gershkovich
in the strongest terms.
We also condemn the Russian
government's continued
targeting and repression of journalists.
- [Narrator] On March 31st,
President Biden urged Russia
to release Gershkovich.
- [Reporter] What's your message
to Russia right now as
they're detaining the-
- To who?
- [Reporter] To Russia
as they're detaining The
Wall Street Journal reporter.
- Let him go.
We're in process.
- [Narrator] Gershkovich
was accredited to work
as a journalist in Russia
by the country's foreign ministry
at the time of his detention.
Biden said the US didn't
plan any expulsion
of Russian journalists
or diplomats in response.
- That's not the plan right now.
- [Narrator] The Wall Street Journal,
editor in chief, Emma Tucker spoke
to CNN's Anderson Cooper
about Gershkovich's detainment
and the charges against him.
- It's utter rubbish.
Evan was doing what reporters do
and what he did very well.
He was out there gathering news,
talking to people, reporting,
providing an eyewitness account
of what's going on inside Russia.
- [Narrator] Speaking at a news conference
on April 3rd, NATO Secretary General,
Jens Stoltenberg said Gershkovich's arrest
was of great concern.
- It is important to respect
freedom of the press,
the rights of journalists, and the rights
to ask questions and to do their job.
So therefore, we call on
his immediate release.
- [Narrator] At the United Nations,
Russia's ambassador declined
to discuss Gershkovich case in any detail,
citing what he referred
to as the separation
of powers in the Russian justice system.
- Today, Secretary Blinken talked
to Minister Lavrov on that issue.
But that will be decided
not by Minister Lavrov
or Secretary Blinken, but by investigation
and by the evidence
that the investigation could provide
for the court.
- Good afternoon, everybody.
- [Narrator] On April 4th,
White House Press secretary,
Karine Jean-Pierre said,
the US will continue
pressing for his release
and seek consular access to him.
- Evan is not a spy.
Evan has never been a spy.
Evan has never worked
for the US government.
- [Narrator] That same day,
Gershkovich's lawyers met with him
in prison and reported that,
"Evan's Health is good and he is grateful
for the outpouring of support
from around the world."
Secretary of State, Antony Blinken said
on April 5th that the
state department's process
to reach an official wrongfully
detained determination was pending.
- In my own mind, there's no doubt
that he's being wrongfully
detained by Russia
which is exactly what I said
to Foreign Minister Lavrov when I spoke
to him over the weekend and insisted
that Evan be released immediately.
But I want to make sure that as always
because there is a formal process,
that we go through it and we will,
and I expect that to be completed soon.
- [Narrator] On April
6th, a Moscow court said
that it would hear an appeal
from Gershkovich's lawyers on April 18th.
The court could uphold
his continued detention,
order him moved to another jail,
allow him house arrest, or grant him bail.
(gentle suspenseful music)